[Musique]
jeudi 9 novembre bienvenue dans le 78
sur tv78 voici les titres de
l'actualité le harcèlement scolaire est
en haut selon une dernière étude de
l'fop le phénomène a déjà touché près
d'un élève sur 5 en France une journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire se rouler aujourd'hui quelle
est la situation dans les Evelin comment
détecter ces violences et que faire si
l'on est une victime élément de réponse
dans cette édition une fresque à Plaisir
dédié aux jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
Graf et sport c'est son nom est visible
sur le mur extérieur du gymnase
nicolasler l'œuvre a été réalisée par le
collectif
pop avec l'aide des enfants de la ville
à l'approche des commémorations de
l'armisti du 11 novembre Versailles
propose une exposition à l'Hôtel de
Ville nourrir les soldats au front
invite à à la réflexion sur
l'alimentation pendant la Première
Guerre mondiale elle est à voir jusqu'au
14 novembre et puis un anniversaire dans
les invités du satute en 2è partie
d'émission l'Atelier des Arts Plastiques
de morpa fait ses 40 ans pour l'occasion
l'association propose une exposition du
11 au 19 novembre à l'espace Albert Camu
nous recevons le président Michel
soulier la vice-présidente Joceline
brizely et comme tous les jeudis
également la sélection des idées de
sortie à faire dans les iblin pour le
weekend de tv78 et ce sera avec vous
Gabriel Montier bonsoir bonsoir Grégori
quel est le menu du jour et bien on
parlera du retour du Paris fermer à
rambouiller une exposition dédiée à
Madagascar ou encore des concerts dans
vos communes ce sera tout à l'heure dans
le 78 et avec vous aussi dans quelques
instants les informations en bref à
retenir de ce jeudi dans les
ivelines mais d'abord ce jeudi c'était
la journée nationale de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire un jeune sur 5
serait confronté à ces violences contre
entre 1/ 10 il y a encore quelques mois
dans les ivelines le suicide du jeune
Nicolas àoissi début septembre a conduit
le gouvernement à établir un plan
interministériel contre le harcèlement
scolaire et cet après-midi des étudiants
de BTS à la Bergerie Nationale de
rambouilla ont organisé une conférence
sur le cyber harcèlement à destination
des lycéens Julien Leroi a profité de
l'occasion pour interviewer sur le sujet
du cyberhcèlement le capitaine landais
de la police nationale qui animait cette
[Musique]
conférence
on est confronté souvent à des cas de
harcèlement des harcèlements qui vont
avoir leur leur origine dans
l'établissement scolaire mais qui
prennent de l'ampleur parce qu'ils se
développe ensuite sur les réseaux
sociaux si il prend autant d'ampleur de
nos jours et s'il est aussi grave en
conséquence puisque malheureusement les
cas de suicide sont très nombreux c'est
parce qu'il il se nourrit des des
réseaux sociaux et de l'usage qui peut
être fait des télé
malheureusement quand les signes sont
visibles ça va plutôt être du repli sur
soi de une personne qui s'isole qui qui
va changer de comportement c'est que le
harcèlement est déjà bien installé et
que les troubles sont là et est durable
moi je je préfère qu'on travaille même
avant que ces signes apparaissent je dis
souvent que les jeunes entre eux
discutent beaucoup et qu'il voit plein
de choses sur les réseaux sociaux ils
sont plusieurs et quand quelqu'un
constate que un de ces cam est souvent
visé et qu'il y a des choses pas bien
qui se passent et ben il faut agir
vite j'ai donnais beaucoup de numéros
verts sur les sur le le harcèlement et
je me suis rendu compte que nos jeunes
ont parfois une difficulté à prendre
leur téléphone et à composer ce numéro
je sais pas c'est une crainte assez
assez récurrente chez les jeunes donc
maintenant ce que je leur dis c'est que
les réseaux sociaux c'est un côté
négatif ça peut servir à harceler mais
c'est un côté extrêmement positif c'est
que ça peut permettre de prendre
beaucoup d'information il existe un site
qui s'appelle stop harcèlement et ce
site peut les aider à libérer leurs
paroles ils peuvent toujours faire un
appel 17 prendre des renseignements
auprès d'un commissariat ou d'une
association d'Aid aux victimes tout le
monde est capable de les aider y compris
leur établissement
[Musique]
scolaire viendront sur cette conférence
sur le cyberhcèlement la semaine
prochaine sur TV 78 le point à présent
sur les informations du jour dans les
ivelines
et c'est avec vous Gabriel la Cour des
comptes vient de publier un rapport
singlant à l'encontre de Catherine
Pégard la présidente du château de
Versailles cumule des mandats limites
d'âge gestion financière plusieurs
points sont abordés dans le rapport de
la Cour des comptes nommé en 2011 par
Nicolas sarkoi Catherine péar a exercé
trois mandats le maximum possible
aujourd'hui elle occupe toujours ce
poste par intérim en plus des mandats
elle dépasse aussi la limite d'âge de 67
ans selon la Cour des comptes son
maintien son maintien je cite pourrait
même être assez assimilé à une forme de
détournement de pouvoir fin de citation
le ministère de la Culture dém cette
accusation il se défend en expliquant
que le nombre cumulé des mandats de
Catherine pégar ne dépasse pas celui
prévu dans le décret statuaire la
situation d'intérim actuelle ne
constituant pas un nouveau mandat la
Cour des comptes pointe également des
dysfonctionnements budgétaires et
réclame un bilan de l'usage des aides
publiques octroyé pendant la crise
sanitaire au château de versaill une
direction HR à présent où certains
habitants sont en colère oui le
département a lancé fin octobre les
premiers travaux du pont d'Acher il doit
relier la départementale 30 et 190
problème des habitants et des
associations environnementales se
mobilisent contre ce projet estimant que
le pont va entraîner une forte pollution
et nuire à la biodiversité un référé
suspension a été déposé aujourd'hui au
tribunal administratif de Versailles par
l'avocat du collectif une pétition
lancée en ligne réunit déjà 8000
signatures une manifestation sera
organisée ce dimanche à André Info
Trafic vous avez une mauvaise nouvelle
Gabriel pour les automobilistes oui à
partir de 22h vendredi et jusqu'à 16h
dimanche la RN10 sera fermée au niveau
de trappe en raison de travaux la
Direction des Routes d'Île-de-France
doit effectuer des opérations
d'inspection sur le pont qui do qui doit
franchir provisoirement la RN10 cela
fait suite à un accident qui a eu lieu
lors des émeutes urbaines la circulation
sera impossible dans les deux sens deux
déviations seront mises en place si vous
souhaitez aller en direction de Paris il
vous faudra prendre la sortie vers la
zone d'activité de trappe et lancour si
vous souhaitez vous rendre vers le sud
des Yvelines vous devrez passer par la
rd912 en direction d'élencours on
termine avec un mot de sport du football
Gabriel vous allez nous parler d'un
joueur yvlinois qui a vu sa carrière
décoller oui on peut parler d'une
successs story greégory Sikou Niakate a
commencé à jouer à 6 ans avec le FC
Saint-Germain en septembre le joueur de
24 ans s'est envolé pour le Portugal où
il évolue en Ligue des Champions avec le
SC Braga hier c'était son premier
premier match face au Real Madrid malgré
la défaite le défenseur central a confié
à nos confrères de l'équipe c'est
exceptionnel je prends un maximum de
plaisir parce que je ne sais pas si je
revivrai ça un jour dans ma carrière on
va dire que j'étais un peu dans le trou
en France et désormis je me frotte aux
plus grands attaquants du monde en un
peu plus d'un an siikou Niakaté et passé
de remplaçant au FC mets à titulaire
avec Braga bravo à lui et Merci à VOUS
Gabriel Gontier on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants pour les idées de
sortie à faire ce weekend dans les
evelines et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous a fait
réagir dans les evelines n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news si vous habité plaisir vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué une frae qui est
désormais visible sur la façade du
gymnase nicoller cette œuvre met à
l'honneur les valeurs des Jeux
Olympiques à l'approche des Joos de
Paris 2024 elle a été réalisée par un
collectif d'artistes art pop avec l'aide
d'enfant de l'espace jeune de la ville
Anne-Sophie mouqué et Julien Leroi après
6 mois d'attente une nouvelle fresque
sur le thème de l'olympisme a vu le jour
au gymnase nicolasler une fresque
remplie d'espoir réalisée par l'espace
jeune de plaisir mettant en avant les
valeurs du sport et l'idée c'était de
mêler des ateliers dans l'espace jeune
qui venaient de commencer dans les
quartiers avec des œuvres d'art ça va
vraiment être une marque une marque je
dirais qui va marquer non seulement
l'événement des gios mais également ce
que nous pensonsnous du sport et et de
la jeunesse de plaisir une marque ayant
réuni artistes et enfants permettant de
tisser des liens et bien plus encore au
début on y arrivait pas trop mais on
s'est entraîné on s'est entraîné et au
bout des heures on a réussi je trouve
que de parler comme ça à la population
par le biais d'œuvre d'art sur des
espaces publics c'est fondamental des
mots d'espoir qui vont perdurer sur la
façade du
gymnase
[Musique]
samedi nous commémorons le 105e
anniversaire de l'Armistice du 11
novembre 1918 et comme chaque année la
Ville de Versailles propose des
expositions à l'approche de cette de
cette date autour de la Première Guerre
mondiale et jusqu'au 14 novembre à la
mairie la ville a choisi la thématique
de l'alimentation avec une exposition
nourrir le soldat au front une
invitation à la réflexion et à la
commémoration et on va regarder tout de
suite votre sujet Gabriel
Montier
[Musique]
si au travers des repas des soldats nous
découvrions une autre histoire de la
Première Guerre mondiale à l'approche
des commémorations du 11 novembre
l'exposition nourrir le soldat au front
invite à la réflexion sur une partie de
l'histoire méconnue mais riche
d'information sur la vie quotidienne
dans les tranchers cette exposition est
intéressante pour deux raisons d'abord
c'est un sujet qui n'est pas tellement
connu qui est l'alimentation des soldat
pendant la guerre et j'ai conçu cette
exposition en miroir c'est-à-dire que je
voulais absolument
présenter le français et l'allemand au
travers des photos des archives et des
lettres de l'époque l'exposition est une
plongée dans la vie au front entre le
ravitaillement les enjeux de
l'alimentation dans la guerre ou encore
le rôle des femmes à l'arrière
contrainte de remplacer les hommes et je
suis très fier de vous présenter la
première boulang française et la
première boulangère allemande une autre
histoire de la guerre qui permet
également de découvrir au travers de
clichés les moments de répi et la vie
sur le front c'est donc une vraie
tranche de sociologie qui nous montre
comment comment on vivait comment on se
nourrit on pouvait se nourrir et pour
nourrir ces soldats qu'est-ce qu'on
devait faire à l'arrière comment on
s'est organisé à l'arrière alors à
l'époque avec les moyens de
l'agriculture locale avec des soldats
qui finalement mangent à peu près la
même chose de tout côtés mais sans doute
de meilleure qualité côté français que
côté allemand des différences dans la
manière de s'alimenter dont témoignent
les maquettes et les rations d'époque et
d'aujourd'hui exposé une façon de
montrer que l'alimentation est toujours
un enjeu majeur de la guerre nous avons
voulu apporter en plus et bien ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui également grâce
commissariat des armées de rambouiller
qui nous ont prêté du matériel toutes
les petites maquettes et des rations des
rations de combat qui ont de certaines
années et les et les récentes celle
d'aujourd'hui proposé gratuitement
l'exposition est à découvrir jusqu'au 14
novembre 2023 à l'hôtel de ville de
Versailles et pour le 11 novembre
Gabriel les communes de 50 ans en
Yveline vont se mobiliser oui à plaisir
par exemple rendez-vous dès 9h à
l'église Saint-Pierre agvi en cours le
rendez-vous a lieu sur le parvis de
l'Hôtel de Ville ville preux commémora
de devant le monument au mort vous le
voyez s'afficher sur votre écran
d'autres commémorations ont lieu au clés
sous-bois à voisin le Bretonneux ou
encore à morpas et à la verrière merci
allez c'est bientôt le weekend c'est
donc l'heure de sortir dans les
[Musique]
yvelinestion tant attendue des idées de
sortie de Gabriel Gontier comme chaque
jeudi dans le 78 on commence avec un
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer pour les
amateurs de produits du terroir et oui
le marché fermier de rambouiller revient
ce weekend près de 110 agriculteurs et
vignerond de toute la France sont
attendus au programme produits fermiers
ambiance conviviale dégustation de vin
et de produits locaux mais aussi de
nombreuses animations autour de la ferme
chaque année c'est près de 10000
visiteurs qui viennent participer à
l'événement début du marché vendredi et
ce jusqu'à dimanche c'est un bon moyen
de se faire plaisir et de soutenir les
producteurs locaux en plus les fêes
approchent donc on peut avoir des idées
avec avec ce marché direction maintenant
le théâre de50 en Eveline où se tient un
spectacle itinérant oui l'ensemble
humelotte propose une nouvelle
exploration des œuvres de la pianiste et
compositrice américaine marieelou
Williams une artiste de jazz peu connue
mais pas moins importante dans
l'histoire du jazz dans ce spectacle
c'est la proximité qui est mise à
l'honneur les arrangements originaux de
l'artiste se mèle à la nouvelle
exploration du groupe une façon de
mettre en avant l'artiste mais aussi les
solistes de l'humelotte je vous propose
grégoryie qu'on écoute un extrait
[Musique]
voyage musical ça tombe bien on va
voyager pour votre prochaine idée de
sortie le centre Alfred dein voisin
lebreteneux nous emmène à Madagascar
avec l'exposition retour sur Madagascar
oui une série de photographies aux
couleurs de sourirees et des coutumes de
l'île de l'océan Indien le président du
Centre Culturel gerérard nuelac propose
une exposition despaysantes au travers
de ces clichés pris lors d'un voyage
associative c'est une mosaïque de peuple
qui est présentée à Notter également
qu'un film sur Madagascar sera diffusé
au C au centre Alfred devini le 16
novembre c'est gratuit et ouvert à tous
un mot pour terminer sur les fêtes
romantiques à croaie sur scène oui
l'association pleel Chopin croissie vous
invite à sa nouvelle saison de concert
sur le thème de la musique romantique
vous l'avez dit cette année encore le
festival propose des récitals sur piano
historique mais aussi des concerts de
musique de chambre donnés par une
playéade d'artistes renommé parmi eux
Jean-Baptiste doulcé ou encore Fanny
azurau un mouvement de musique classique
qui met au premier plan l'expression des
sentiment l'occasion de revisiter Chopin
ou encore choubert au travers d'un
voyage temporel de 1820 28 à 1872 merci
Gabriel avant d'accueillir les invités
du 78 coup d'œil aux prévisions météo
des prochains jours dans les
Yvelines un peu de soleil demain matin
sur le territoire yvelinois des
éclaircis sont prévus pour les
températures compté 7°gr à rambouilla et
Versailles 8°gr à Houdan 9 à
mantelajolie il devrait pleuvoir en
revanche demain après-midi avec un
thermomètre compris entre 10 et 11°r
dans tous les secteurs des Eveline et ce
vendredi 10 novembre nous fêterons les
léones ce weekend c'est miifig miaisin
avec un temps sec samedi et des
éclaircis les minimales descendront
jusqu'à 2°gr dans le sud du département
et les maximales monteront à 13°gr enfin
dimanche de la pluie les températures
seront comprises entre 3 et 4°grés pour
les minimales et de 11 à 13°grés pour
les maximales et donc voilà pour la
météo du weekend tout de suite les
invités du
et on va fêter un anniversaire ce soir
dans le 78 celui des ateliers des arts
plastiques de morpas à l'occasion de ces
40 ans l'association morpasienne propose
une exposition elle est à voir du 11 au
19 novembre à l'espace Albert Camu les
horaires vous les voyez s'afficher
14h18h et pour parler de cet événement
pour parler aussi de ces 40 ans deux
invités qui sont avec nous en plateau le
présid prident de l'association Michel
souier bonsoir et à vos côté la
viceprésidente Joceline briiselet
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
bah petit tour de parole pour commencer
40 ans ça représente quoi pour vous 40
ans pour l'association 40 ans c'est la
force de
l'âge donc ni trop vieux ni trop jeune
plein de vie donc notre atelier est en
plein dynamisme en plein développement
même au bout de 40 ans on a à peu près
une centaine d'adhérents 65 adultes et 5
enfants
et on espère bien continuer comme ça
encore pendant des années de
l'expérience et une longue vie encore
derrière Joceline briisel euh on espère
bien oui oui c'est bien parti pour et ça
ça représente quoi pour vous ces 40 ans
c'est aussi 40 ans de ma vie parce que
j'étais là pratiquement au début de de
cette association et donc voilà je l'ai
vu évoluer parce qu'on a commencé très
petit et on est maintenant quand même à
une centaine alors qu'on a dû commencer
à enfin moi j'y étais pas tout à fait la
première les premières années mais au
bout de 2 ans je sais pas il y avait 15
personnes voilà et puis c'est c'est
devenu de plus en plus gros on a aussi
eu plusieurs professeurs alors qu'au
départ il y en avait un seulement voilà
a eu plusieurs évolutions al pour
présenter les les ateliers ils sont nés
en 1980 créé à l'époque par François
joliver ancien élève de l'École
Nationale supérieur des beauxards à
Paris quels sont les objectifs Michel
souliier de cette association B les
objectifs c'est
d'abord de de développer les arts
plastiques au sein de la ville deampa
faire participer un maximum de de monde
d'enseigner aussi les arts plastiques
aux enfants qui est relativement
important et puis aussi de faire des
expositions au SE comme celle-ci
d'ailleurs au sein de la ville de morpa
de se faire connaître de rayonner un peu
de faire connaître les arts plastiques
on parle beaucoup de musique mais des
arts plastiques aussi euh voilà enfin
nos objectifs c'est principalement et
les activités quelles sont-elles de
l'association alors principalement euh
peinture mais aussi
dessin aquarelle modèles vivants on a
des modèles vivants régulièrement et
donc oui les cours d'enfants et aussi
des stages de sculpture une fois par an
à peu près ouis alors vous parlez du
nombre d'adhérents et aussi des
différents âges il y a des enfants il y
a des des adultes ça mèle tous les âges
alors il y a des enfants de 9 à 10 enfin
des enfants et des jeunes de 9 à 18 ans
même des 6 ans de 6 ans de 6 ans oui
pardon de 6 ans oui parce qu'il y a les
cours 6 9 oui voilà de 6 ans à 18 ans
après 18 ans il passe du côté des
adultes des fois on fait une exception
parce qu'il y a des aménagements un
petit peu mais enfin bon à partir du 18
ans il passe au niveau des adultes
jusqu'à
9 oui on a une adhérente qui a 93 je
crois un petit peu de mal à venir
maintenant mais enfin bon on a eu des
gens quand même voilà donc c'est à peu
près tous les âges il y a peut-être un
petit déficit au niveau des des des 30
40 ans euh alors pourquoi je sais pas
parce que les gens sont occupés par leur
boulot et cetera alors on a des cours le
soir pour ces gens-là le jeudi soir donc
de 19h30 à
22h3030 moi j'y suis allé longtemps
aussi quand j'étais actif j'ai commencé
à participer à l'atelier en 82 un peu
comme Joseline donc mais après j'ai eu
une longue période d'inactivité donc il
a voilà vous adaptez à tous les âges aux
différents emplois du temps de chacun
GAB av ou justement vous parliez des
très jeunes adhérents j'imagine qu'il y
en a que vous avez vu évoluer au fil des
années qu'est-ce que ça leur a apporté
fin surtout Joseline parce queelle s'up
des adolescents principalement donc
effectivement je les ai vu commencer à 6
ans avec une collègue et euh donc ils
atterrissent chez moi vers 12 13 ans et
je les ai vu là je sais plus ils ont 28
ou ou plus et ils font des des écoles
d'art quelquesuns bien sûr dans le lot
il y en a qui sont très doués et qui
choisissent cette voie là pour certains
ça leur a permis de trouver vraiment une
vocation ex oui oui oui oui alors qui
sont les professeurs vous en faites
partie si j'ai bien compris les
professeurs moi enseignant des aux
adolescents seulement et donc qui sont
les professeurs sinon sinon on a des
professeurs salariés hein on a quatre
professeurs salariés donc un le le le
jeudi pour l'aquarelle ou le modèle
vivant c'est une nouvelle professeur on
a un autre professeur pour le la
peinture le jeudi après-midi et le jeudi
soir et un autre professeur pour le
vendredi matin pour la peinture juste
avant qu'on parle de de l'exposition
votre passion pour vous pour les arts
plastiques votre passion à vous elle
vous vient d'où Jim brisé tout toute
jeune je voulais m'orienter vers ce vers
ce domaine là et à à mon époque c'était
pas très bien considéré et voilà et et
dès que j'ai que j'ai eu mon premier
enfant je me suis réorienté vers ça et
mais c'est c'est une vocation quoi
toujours ouiou ou aussi sur mes cahers
de cours à l'école dans T les la marge
toujours les petits dessins euh et puis
les cours de dessin à l'école bon benah
j'étais toujours aussi un peu le premier
en fait parce que j'aimais ça et puis je
dessine à chez moi et tout et en étant
actif après bon c'est plus dur mais j'ai
je crois que j'ai toujours dessiné et
peint toute ma vie quoi donc c'est c'est
des passionnés qui composent cette
association donc on disait qu'il fait
ses 40 ans et à l'occasion de ces 40 ans
il y a donc cette exposition qui va se
dérouler du côté de l'espace Albert Camu
de de morpa c'est important pour vous de
proposer ce rendez-vous pour marquer le
coup pour fêter ces 40 ans oui oui B 40
ans ça ça se fait on a d'ailleurs une
médaille par la ville de morpa il y a
pas longtemps il y avait une réunion des
associations pour les anniversaires on
voit l'installation de l'exposition elle
est pas encore tout à fait installé
voilà oui on l' VO en cours donc on a eu
une médaille de la ville de morpa pour
les 40 ans ça nous a permis d'attraper
le covid parce que cétais en plein covid
et que
contamination et 40 ans oui c'est
important oui
bah distance tous les G d'une viei et
puis une association quand même faut la
faire vivre il faut des bénévoles il
faut un les présidents des secrétaires
trésorers vous manquez de bénévol ou non
non on manque pas de bénévole mais enfin
ça bouscule pas plus bouscule pas non
plus oui mais bon il y a des relations
amicales aussi depuis le temps par on
est quelques anciens comme ça on a vu
quelquesunes des œuvres qu'est-ce qui
sera au programme de cette exposition
justement qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait voir
euh beaucoup de de végétaux de de thèm
sur l'arbre et puis qu'est-ce qui est a
souvent des thèmes mais bon là qu'est-ce
que c'est assez varié en fait parce que
les élèves en fait on prop on propose en
début d'année des thèmes mais bon
certains les suivent et puis mais il y a
pas d'imposition on les propose
simplement après les thèmes sont libre
pour chacun le rôle du professeur étant
de de permettre à l'élève de de
développer son style dans thèm qu'il a
choisi surtout en étant créatif c'estd
éviter les copies d'avoir une photo et
puis de regarder si le bleu il
exactement pareil enfin bon après
finalement c'est la créativité qui
crétivité qui prime ouab et justement on
retrouve les œuvres de tous vos élèves
même les plus jeunes ceux qui débutent
ah non alors là on a on a choisi que les
adultes parce que en raison de la place
aussi voilà mais tous les ans il y a une
petite expo dans le hall de Albert Camu
pour nos élèves enfants voilà qui sont
mises à l'honneur combien de temps ça
vous a pris pour préparer
cette exposition bah il y a d'abord les
réunions de conseil d'administration oui
ça prend du temps pour
préparer sélectionner les res au sein
des cours ramener les œuvres sur le
Albert Camu cet après-midi il y a
accrochage avec un professeur telle
façon à avoir un accrochage homogène non
ça prend du temps enfin demain continuer
TR travail sur plusieurs jours plusieurs
mois plusours ou ENF 3 jours si on
considère vraiment le travail de
l'exposition c'est 3 jours plein là et
on l'a pas précisé l'entrée est libre
pour cetteosition donc on peut venir
directement sur place pas besoin de
réserver non non non non on a les
informations sur le le site internet de
l'association qui va peut-être
s'afficher il est sur sur l'animation
qui relaie les les différentes
informations voilà les informations
pratiques pour pour cette exposition qui
je le disais se déroule du 11 au 19
novembre de 14h à 18h chaque jour à
l'espace Albert Camu de morpa le
www.artema.fr si vous voulez plus
d'informations une dernière question qui
concerne votre association comment vous
rejoindre et combien coûte l'adhésion à
Laan on a un site qui s'appelle
artema.fr sur lesquel il y a toutes les
informations et on peut venir aussi à
notre atelier qui est au 5 allées du
Bourbonnet à morpa juste à côté de la
poste donc voilà et puis sur le site il
y a il y a un contact lequel on peut et
le coût de l'adhésion à peu près environ
l'adhésion c'est dans les 30 ou 40 €
ceci dit si on prend des cours il faut
payer en plus les cours donc toutes les
informations vous l'AVE dit sur votre
site site internet merci à vous deux
d'être venu en plateau et bon
anniversaire à vous aux ateliersar
plastique de de morpa et je le disais on
vaevoir peut-être une dernière fois les
les informations cette exposition à
l'occasion de vos 40 ans qui se déroule
du 11 au 19 novembre à l'espace Albert
Camu de morpa l'entrée est libre voilà
c'est la fin de ce 78 merci de votre
fidélité j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver dès lundi pour une nouvelle
édition et d'ici là passez bien sûr un
excellent weekend sur
tv78
[Musique]